Amy Schumer is one of the big honorees
at the British GQ Men of the Year awards
in London last night and um Cameron and
I have both had the honor of sitting
across from her and talking to miss you
more before and it's scary you've gotta
be on your toes with us you never know
what she is going to say next last night
was a great example right about that Amy
speech jaws dropping cheek human of the
year finally we are celebrating men it's
why we love Amy cracking us up although
we can only show you the tame jokes as
she picked up British gqueues Woman of
the Year award thank you for coming yet
woman and that I love you
hard to believe this was Schumer's first
red carpet with her man of nine months
banished they color-coordinated in black
Amy told me he's not like her other
boyfriends he's not a narcissist and
he's just very supportive and loving and
and I think we're just really proud of
each other
this is embarrassing I wrote a list I
thought I was the model of the year so
this speech doesn't even make sense
where's models Ashley Graham and Bella
Hadid present Amy went for it unfiltered
in recalling the last time she was at a
podium in London and I got drunk at an
award show and then I woke up in the
morning and there was a viral video of
me at the glamour Awards I'm probably
like a hundred sixty pounds right now
and I can catch it whenever I want like
that
so I decided to keep it a little lower
key tonight just say like thank you
backstage Amy grab some selfies with
Ricky Gervais and Patrick Stewart she
was in the UK for two nights of shows
but took time for a pint with boyfriend
Ben London you think Amy's funny in
these clips wait till you see her
stand-up her comedy tour will bring her
back home to the states one week from
today and the u.s. leg begins with three
dates in California